in this video you're gonna learn how to
factor the sum and difference of two
cubes so the first thing that you want
to know are the formulas of course we're
gonna go over that but you also want to
know these perfect cubes these common
ones that come up over and over again
like 1 cubed is 1 & 2 cubed is 8 and 10
cubed is a thousand so see if you can
memorize these that'll be helpful for
recognizing when you have sum of two
cubes or a difference of two cubes now
the next thing we want to look at here
is the formula and when you think about
a perfect cube plus a perfect cube what
you want to do is you want to take the
cube root of this quantity you want to
take the cube root of this quantity so
you can figure out what your a and B
values are and then we're go ahead and
substitute in this formula as seen here
now that acronym that a lot of students
memorize when they're learning sum of
two cubes in difference of two cubes is
this soap acronym and what it stands for
is same opposite always positive so if
you're adding this is the same you're
going to be adding then the next sign is
going to be the opposite you're gonna be
subtracting and the last one is always
positive so that's just a nice way of
remembering also when you do a
difference of two cubes same thing when
you're subtracting C it's the same
you're subtracting then the opposite and
then always positive so the only thing
you really have to memorize then are a
and B a squared a B and B squared it's
the same for both formulas it's just
that the signs are different so let's
jump into these four examples and I'll
show you how to work with these the
first one x cubed minus 27 C if I take
the cube root of x cubed C that's really
gonna be like just axe so this is like
our a value when I take the cube root of
27 that's 3 all right so this is going
to be like our B value so we're
subtracting so this is a difference of
two cubes so we're gonna start off with
X minus 3 so that's a minus B then x
squared the opposite sign plus 8 times B
which is 3 X always positive B squared
so 3 times 3 which is 9 now a lot of
students will say well Mario can't you
factor this trinomial further and when
you're doing these sum of two cubes in
difference of two cubes this won't be
able to be factored any further that's
as far as we can go so this is your
final result and you've got it factored
now keep in mind when you're factoring
you always want to look for that
greatest common factor first
if there isn't a greatest common factor
then you can analyze is it a sum of two
cubes difference of two cubes and
proceed from there
so let's look at a more difficult one
now number two we've got eight y cubed
plus one so what quantity times itself
three times is eight Y cubed well that's
going to be 2y times 2y times 2y and
what times itself three times is one
well that's just going to be one so
sometimes people overlook one as a
perfect cube now the reason I wrote it
like this is just to identify the a
value and the B value so a is 2y B is
one we're adding so we're gonna want to
use this formula here at the top and
we're going to follow that soap acronym
so we've got a plus B so this is the
same we're adding we're adding then
we've got a squared so 2i times 2y is 4y
squared because this was adding we want
to now do the opposite minus a times B
which is 2y and the last is always going
to be positive B squared so 1 times 1
which is 1 and now you've got it fully
factored see if you can do number 3 and
4 we're gonna go through them together
what time's itself is 64 d cubed well
you can see 64 is 4 to the third power
so this is really going to be 4 D 2 it's
4 D times 4 D or 40 cubed 125 is 5 cubed
and so now this is going to be our a and
our B in our formula so following that
soap pattern that acronym we're going to
say a minus B a squared which is 40
times 40 which is 16 d squared opposite
since we subtracted here we're doing the
opposite adding here a times B so for D
times 5 is 20 D plus B squared which is
5 squared which is 25 remember the last
one's always positive and that's it
you've got it fully factored ok last
example see if you can do this one 216 C
cubed plus a thousand DQ
this one what times itself three times
is 216 well you can see that's going to
be six cubed so this is going to be six
see what times itself three times is a
thousand well that's going to be ten
cubed so this is going to be ten D the
quantity cube so this is our a and this
is our B so now if we put it all
together we've got a plus B okay see
this is adding so we're adding that's
the same then we've got a squared which
is going to be six C times six C that's
36 C squared and then the opposite so if
we're adding we subtract that's going to
be a times B that's 60 C D and the last
one is always positive that's going to
be e squared 10 D times 10 D which is a
hundred d squared and you've got it
fully factored if you want to see more
examples of factoring specifically how
to factor all different types I show you
like a decision tree like how to decide
what to do first second third follow me
over to that really comprehensive video
right there where I dive into all the
different types I'll see you in that
video